[Música]
líbano va a las urnas este domingo en
unas elecciones parlamentarias a las que
llegan en un clima de descontento social
en medio de la peor crisis económica de
su historia reciente
el bloqueo ruso en los puertos del mar
negro y el mar de azov asfixia a ucrania
que no puede exportar sus cereales el
escenario representa una amenaza para la
seguridad alimentaria mundial
y con consignas como basta de controlar
nuevos miles de personas a lo largo de
eeuu salieron en las calles para
defender el derecho al aborto y rechazar
el proyecto de la corte suprema de
justicia de revocarlo
hola bienvenidos a las noticias de
france 24 en español gracias por
acompañarnos hoy santiago y que
comenzamos esta emisión en líbano que
este domingo celebra elecciones
parlamentarias en medio de la peor
crisis económica de su historia reciente
con la indignación de los libaneses por
la explosión del puerto de beirut y la
renuncia histórica del líder político
saad hariri como telón de fondo en este
ambiente los comicios podrían tener unos
resultados inesperados que cambiaría en
el equilibrio de poderes en el país el
informe es de éter burnett y diego
ibarra sánchez
mustafa la uicc pertenece a ese grupo de
jóvenes políticos suníes que han sido
fieles al ex primer ministro saad hariri
y al movimiento futuro pero ahora con la
ausencia dejar ir en la política
libanesa mustafa busca abrirse su propio
camino como candidato independiente en
trípoli el mayor feudo suní la ciudad
más pobre del mediterráneo y la ausencia
de hariri trae ventajas y desventajas a
la comunidad sin la fidelidad a hariri
durante décadas ha hecho que él haya
estado por encima y no con la gente
ahora tenemos la oportunidad de elegir
nuevos líderes
el 20 se preocupen por su gente y
ser candidato independiente no es fácil
si no se tiene apoyo financiero mustafa
cuenta con recursos limitados por lo que
para darse a conocer visita directamente
a los vecinos para conocer y discutir
los problemas del barrio alberdi
la gente no tiene esperanza en las
elecciones piensa que nada va a cambiar
pero se equivocan yo creo en el cambio
democrático hacer que trípoli vuelva a
ser la segunda del país revitalizar el
puerto y su economía the family look del
zenit líbano es un país confesional
donde cada afecta tiene una cuota de
poder y trípoli es clave para el voto
son y los tripolitanos son gente
religiosa y tradicional acostumbrada a
la lealtad de un líder por más de 30
años esa figura ha sido rafic hariri y
después su hijo saad por el que es muy
difícil arrancar su memoria del corazón
de cecco lo de matt hardy de filo para
mí sí hariri se acabó el líbano sí
hariri no ha podido sacarnos de la
crisis económica a nadie no existo nadie
podrá salvar la uar
pero no todos los suníes están tristes
por la partida de hariri para ibrahim
que lleva toda una vida en esta esquina
remendando zapatos el cambio puede ser
positivo ha habido tiempos buenos y
malos con ari pero ha cambiado su tiempo
ahora le toca a otro y espero que haga
las cosas bien en la emblemática plaza
de acnur símbolo de poderse unir aquí en
trípoli nuevos rostros ocupan los
carteles electorales la decisión de
hariri de abandonar la vida política
además de haber creado un vacío de poder
entre los suníes ha aumentado el temor
de que hizbulá pueda ganar más espacio
político
vamos a orar con información sobre
algunas de las consecuencias de la
guerra en ucrania el bloqueo ruso en los
puertos del mar negro y de marea sobre
está asfixiando a ucrania que no puede
exportar sus cereales una amenaza para
la seguridad alimentaria mundial dado
que quien es uno de los principales
productores mundiales de maíz y de trigo
desde la tribuna y frente a sus
homólogos del g7 la ministra alemana de
asuntos exteriores acusa a rusia de
organizar una crisis alimentaria mundial
bloqueando las exportaciones de cereales
ucranianos
hasta 55 millones de personas sobre todo
en los países africanos pero también en
medio oriente gente que va a morir de
hambre en los próximos meses tenemos el
desafío de saber cómo vamos a satisfacer
las necesidades de esas poblaciones
cuarto exportador mundial de cereales
ucrania provisionaba antes de la guerra
el 12% del trigo y el 15 del maíz
mundial pero ahora todos los puertos
ucranianos situados a lo largo del mar
de azov como mariupol y bears yanks
están bloqueados mismo problema por el
lado de gerzón y odessa porque rusia
prohíbe la circulación de todos sus
buques en esta parte del mar negro por
lo tanto los europeos buscan rutas
alternativas una parte de las mercancías
está siendo enviada en tren o en
camiones desde dónde está hasta el
puerto de constanta en rumanía desde
aquí los buques pueden efectuar sus
entregas hacia el resto del mundo pero
esta solución de emergencia no permite
exportar una cantidad suficiente 20
millones de toneladas de cereales
estarían todavía bloqueadas en el puerto
de odessa por otro lado los ataques
rusos apuntan de manera regular a
infraestructuras de producción o de
almacenamiento de cereales en ucrania
según autoridades de este país una parte
de las cosechas está siendo saqueada por
el ejército ruso
noticias de américa latina' miles de
estudiantes salieron este viernes en las
calles de diversas ciudades de perú para
protestar contra la reforma
universitaria y contra el proyecto de
ley 904 que han generado la oposición de
colectivos educativos y en francés 24
diálogos con jan martínez presidente del
centro de estudiantes de administración
de la universidad nacional del callao y
esto nos decía sobre los puntos más
polémicos de estas medidas
básicamente nosotros como estudiantes
universitarias hemos salido a nivel
nacional a marchar en contra de las
contrarreformas que se vienen impulsando
desde comienzos de la república
básicamente porque está queriendo auto
empoderar a los rectores y queriendo que
la universidad sea una autarquía no ya
que el asumido como un ente fiscalizador
debe ser un ente autónomo pero las leyes
que se están aprobando del congreso
están desbaratando el consejo directivo
y están poniendo una figura
representativa de los mismos rectores de
las universidades en el consejo
directivo de las médulas que convertiría
a este espacio en juez y parte de un
proceso de fiscalización es de calidad y
educativa así también como el proyecto
de 204 que elimina la educación integral
sexual en los colegios lo cual nosotros
creemos que bastante peligroso porque en
perú hay bastantes índices de violencia
sexual violación acoso que los
estudiantes de educación básica regular
los escolares deberían desde los
colegios aprender a estas normas a
aprender esa educación para tener una
contingencia mayor en los tiempos
venideros
quien eeuu se debió a un nuevo episodio
de violencia armada al menos 10 personas
murieron en un tiroteo perpetrado en un
supermercado en búfalo nueva york un
joven de 18 años armado con un rifle y
portando un chaleco antibalas abrió
fuego en el sitio antes de ser detenido
y comparecerá por primera vez ante la
justicia el martes próximo las
autoridades dijeron que el ataque que
ocurrió en un vecindario con población
mayoritariamente afroamericana sería
investigado como un crimen de odio el
alcalde de búfalo bryant brown ofreció
detalles sobre los hechos
y estaba fuertemente armado tenía equipo
y casco táctico tenía una cámara que
transmitía en directo lo que estaba
haciendo el individuo salió de su coche
y se enfrentó a cuatro individuos
disparó a cuatro personas en el
estacionamiento tres de ellas murieron
la otra está siendo atendida como dije
es un hombre blanco de 18 años entró y
comenzó a atacar a los clientes dentro
de la tienda
y más noticias llegan necesitados unidos
ciudad de todo el país salieron a las
calles y lo hicieron para mostrar su
descontento con el proyecto de la corte
suprema de justicia de revocar el
derecho al aborto el informe es de
rafael pérez
multitudinarias protestas en favor del
aborto en eeuu en washington la capital
miles de personas se reunieron a
manifestarse con el objetivo de llegar
hasta la corte suprema para demostrar su
descontento con el alto tribunal
esto luego de la filtración de un
borrador preliminar en el que la corte
de mayoría conservadora consideraría
revocar un fallo histórico conocido como
roe versus wave que garantice el acceso
al aborto en todo el país
cuanto más tiempo perdamos más mujeres
morirán por esto porque los abortos
ocurrirán de manera independiente y
resultará en más muerte para las mujeres
particularmente desfavorecidas y
marginadas porque las mujeres ricas van
a viajar a donde es legal pero si no
tienes esos recursos vas a buscar
abortos que no son seguros
en varias ciudades se desarrollaron
concentraciones similares convocadas por
grupos a favor de la interrupción legal
del embarazo como women's march y
planned parenthood a ritmo de tambor y
con exigencias idénticas también hubo
movilizaciones en nueva york' allí
chatham el líder de la mayoría demócrata
en el senado se unió a las
demostraciones en defensa del derecho al
aborto
no quiero que me obliguen a tener un
hijo mientras todavía soy una niña
simplemente no creo que las personas que
son víctimas de violación y agresión
sexual deban tener hijos de su agresor
en este contexto texas considerada un
bastión conservador en la materia no
estuvo exenta de las concentraciones el
estado sureño prohíbo el proceso de
interrupción desde que se registra la
actividad cardiaca en el feto las
marchas se suceden días después del
fallido intento demócrata de lanzar una
iniciativa en el legislativo para
proteger el aborto a nivel federal la
iniciativa naufragó en el senado del
partido de gobierno no alcanzó los votos
suficientes es todo por el momento pero
regresamos en breve con más noticias
sigan en france 24
[Música]